hey
what's up guys last week the fine
brothers made an awesome video called
kids react to corridor digital featuring
us
and kids so ben and rafi fine have a
show on youtube called kids react which
you guys have probably heard of some of
you are probably subscribed to it many
of you have at least seen one episode
kids watch our videos they reacted to it
and it was funny because we don't
usually actually get to see people
reacting to our videos you guys should
go check it out by the way if you
haven't it actually kind of got us
thinking
we really like when people actually give
us in-depth criticism and comments and
reactions on our videos it helps us
learn and helps us grow
and these days like when we put up a
video we get lots and lots of comments
of hey cool hey i liked it nice work
and i kind of we kind of missed the uh
they confused the looks and the slat
shot reactions like those kids made no
we kind of
we kind of missed the days of people
actually giving us really like
constructive feedback and really giving
us in-depth reviews whenever you guys
give us deep criticism on any of our
videos we actually really appreciate it
and we always read that stuff yeah we
take it to heart and usually we start
doubting ourselves pretty tough
we're not very good at handling it
that's not true anyways hopefully this
wind isn't affecting the audio too much
and you actually could understand what
we said we just wanted to say that we
appreciate you guys watching our stuff
we appreciate all the feedback you guys
give cause it helps us grow as
filmmakers
you know just like you guys we're trying
to improve with every single video that
we make so if you want to send us a
message uh don't send it through the
youtube messaging system that's that
doesn't work very well facebook not
really much either but we definitely
read everything on twitter and we
definitely read every single email we
get and whenever we upload a new video
we always read all the youtube comments
for at least a couple days after the
video is uploaded we tend not to go back
and check old videos very often but if
you guys leave in-depth comments on the
video we will read them you're also
welcome to email us contact quarter
digital if you guys ever want to give us
a full blown written review anyways guys
thanks for watching it means a lot to us
that you guys come back and watch our
stuff that you subscribe to our stuff
and when you share with your friends it
makes a world of difference because
that's that's what lets us keep doing
this so check out the kids react video
it's pretty sweet if you got something
to say send it
all right
the easiest second channel video we ever
made
hey that's not supposed to be on camera
you